uh the the thing that i'm really
intrigued by is like
does the business model of silicon
valley actually make sense right so you
know i have my iphone right here
if you think about like what an iphone
is it really is a thing that gets you to
stare at it as much as possible
so that it can take your data and then
sell it back to you in the form of
targeted advertising there's a pretty
good argument that the silicon valley
business model
which distracts a lot of attention and
effectively is built upon the theft of
data
should be completely outlawed right and
make it illegal to sort of
you know collect people's data without a
whole host of additional protections
i think that would blow up the model of
silicon valley i think maybe that's
that's that's that's too radical
but if i'm actually laying my car hey as
a as a guy that just started a tech
company that's doing subscription and
doesn't sell data
keep keep it going keep it going
so where do you fit into that like in
terms of your beliefs at this point
um are they are they all traditionally
conservative i mean i get what you're
saying you could maybe be
thought of as as one of those you know
15 year ago uh
blue dog democrat types but like what
would say your broad
sort of idea set look like yeah i mean
there are some traditionally
conservative ideas that i'm very
comfortable with so so i'm very pro-life
i've always been pro-life i've always
cared a lot about that issue because i
think
you know when abortion becomes
widespread in society what effectively
does is send a message to families
that their babies are inconveniences
instead of you know real like blessings
for us to support
so so on some issues i'm very
traditionally conservative you know but
like one issue for example where i
depart pretty
strongly from the traditional republican
line is i think a lot of folks
in the republican party they see what's
going on with google apple facebook with
big tech writ large
and they say well we don't like what
they're doing we don't like the fact
that they censor conservatives but
they're private companies and so we
can't actually do anything with them
and my response to that is well first of
all they're not actually private
companies they benefit from a ton of
special government privileges
but also they're just too powerful like
however they got there
they're way too powerful and they're way
too big at this point so i'm willing to
go
you know with with ken buck and with
josh hawley and with others and say look
we've got to actually reign in the power
of these companies because if they
control what you're allowed to say in
america
we don't have a first amendment anymore
if we don't have the first amendment we
don't have a real country
yeah it's interesting because i've
discussed this with tucker on his show
many times and years like two or three
years ago i was still like no regulation
don't touch anything the libertarian
side of me
and i actually have come more towards
what you just laid out there which is
what
josh hawley's been laying out but what
do you think that actually looks like
because
if the founders could have never
imagined something more powerful than
the government which is what we've got
i mean do you want to send government
bureaucrats to look at the google
algorithm as if they could do it or
or is it breaking these companies up i
mean i know you like the competition
side and we'll talk about rumble in just
a little bit
but like what does it actually look like
that you would want done to bigtech
yeah yeah so so yeah you're bracketing
the things you can still do in the
private sector which i think is
important i think that there are there
are ranges of options from less radical
to more radical right
so i think a slightly less radical
option is you just make
in the same way that like you can't
censor somebody because they're black or
because they're white
you well you know you used to not be
able to do that over the last couple of
years
yeah yeah yeah give it a couple more
months
you can't for example turn off an
electric utility can't turn off
somebody's
power because they don't you know like
the sex or the gender or the race of the
people who
need the power i think one thing you
could do is just add political
viewpoint to that protected class say if
you're a conservative and you're
censored on facebook
you basically have a right to file a
lawsuit in the same way that if you're
censored because you're black you have a
right to file a wall so that's that's
sort of
you know option one i think a little bit
more radical is the anti-trust option
effectively breaking up these companies
making it impossible
uh for them to sort of control the
discourse because you have more
competition among the platforms that are
out there
you know i i'm i'm basically supportive
of that though i think that you have to
do it the right way or effectively these
sort of companies just reform as natural
monopolies
uh the the thing that i'm really
intrigued by is like
does the business model of silicon
valley actually make sense right so you
know i have my iphone right here
if you think about like what an iphone
is it really is a thing that gets you to
stare at it as much as possible
so that it can take your data and then
sell it back to you in the form of
targeted advertising there's a pretty
good argument that the silicon valley
business model
which distracts a lot of attention and
effectively is built upon the theft of
data
should be completely outlawed right and
make it illegal to sort of
you know collect people's data without a
whole host of additional protections
uh i think that would blow up the model
of silicon valley i think maybe that's
that's
that's that's too radical uh but if i'm
actually laying my car
hey as a as a guy that just started a
tech company that's doing subscription
and doesn't sell data
keep keep it going keep it going but but
i have to say that
that honestly i i would be supportive of
that if you basically said you can no
longer effectively steal people's data
i think that would be really good for
our country and i actually think it
would be
good for the tech sector because like
the tech sector
whether it's in digital technology or
pharmaceuticals or you know energy and
transportation
like it's become a little bit like these
devices i think have become a little
parasitic
on capital on high quality talent and
there's this weird way where our entire
economy like
silicon valley has worked pretty well if
you look at the s p 500 silicon valley
has great returns in their companies
but like the entire rest of the country
and the entire rest of the economy has
been relatively stagnant
that's a big problem that's not just a
censorship problem that's a broader
economic problem
but i think we have to be worried about
that problem too so i'm pretty radical
on this in other words
go after their special privileges break
them up maybe even
illegalize the entire business model
because i care about having a real
economy in a real country again
at some level though do you think it's
just kind of too late like we had
trump for four years we had all the
hearings we all saw
zuckerberg and jack from twitter and the
rest of them trot out there and
basically make up a lot of nonsense half
the time under oath
right and we did and we didn't do
anything then so why would the biden
administration that obviously is
is no fan of some of the ideas you're
putting out there why would they be the
ones to do this
well i don't think they're going to be
the ones to do this i mean i definitely
think it's going to be a combination of
leverage from republican senators and
hopefully i'm one in the not too distant
future
it's also going to require a new
republican administration i think again
all this stuff is going to happen on the
right because the left
is way too in the pocket of the big tech
industry
um all that said you know i try to take
a very long view on this you may know
this guy nigel farage he's sort of the
leader yeah
of the uk i've gotten drunk with him
okay well he's yeah he's a good guy to a
good guy to have a beer with
um you know one of the things that i've
taken just from getting to know nigel a
little bit is like the brexit
thing took 25 years of institution
building of convincing voters
of convincing media a ton of
institutional biases against the brexit
movement
electorally there were some weird issues
of course the media
hated nigel farage and thought he was a
terrible person so i
i i tend to think about this in in a
longer term way that like the goal here
isn't to fix this tomorrow
yes you know i i wish that more could
have happened over the last four years
and actually addressing the tech problem
but i think we take that attitude it can
become self-defeating and what we have
to do in this moment
is actually gear ourselves up for a
fight in a long-term fight
and if we do that i actually think the
people are with us i think that we're on
the right side of this issue
and will eventually win it just may take
some work and a lot of time
yeah do you think we just need a sort of
separation from
all of the institutions that the left
has built that we're now watching
crumble i mean do we need to just build
new institutions new technological uh
answers and solutions just just really
like a complete
parallel economy uh yeah i mean i think
we probably do
um we need to build parallel businesses
of course because the businesses have
gone
fully in the tank for the left like the
biggest multinational corporations are
now effectively
um enterprises of the left i also think
we have to build alternative educational
institutions
you know one of the things the left has
been incredibly effective at
is monopolizing education in this
country right they've basically created
a system
whereby if you don't get a four-year
college degree it's very hard to even
apply for most middle class jobs right
even if they don't really require a
college degree they'll put it right on
the application like you know four-year
degree or
required and and so what this has done
is is forced
a lot of people who just want to have a
middle class life
into the university system they've
acquired a lot of debt they've of course
acquired a lot of indoctrination along
the way
like the left is in some ways like in
this
evil machiavellian sense sort of genius
because they've
made the most left-leaning institutions
the gatekeeper of a good life in this
society
conservatives have got to find an
alternative to this because we keep on
forcing all of our kids
to go to four-year colleges we shouldn't
be surprised that we keep on losing the
culture war
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell